and earlier this year we just sold to
appFolio and which is where I am
building out the product scaling it and
adapting the product to their client
base got it
mind if I ask how much did you guys sell
it for well it's public for people who
want to know mind if I do my research
and put in my video I guess I guess I
can just tell you because you're gonna
put it on anyways we sold 460 million
before we continue this video I just
want to say thank you brilliant for
sponsoring this video every day
brilliant publishes daily challenges on
many stem topics like math science and
computer science this site is extremely
sleek and they have over 60 interactive
courses which makes learning these
concepts way easier because of the
hands-on approach they also have a
artificial neural networks course which
is really really well made and I think
if you're very interested in ml you
should definitely check it out this is a
great complement to University because
you can do practice questions under well
curated sequences of problems which
allows you to master the topic you want
to master you know I wish I had
brilliant when I was in college because
I'm more of a hands-on cam guy
I learned by practicing and if I had
brilliant I think I would have
understood these concepts a lot faster
so if you're interested you can go on
brilliant
org slash Joma and then the first 200
people will get 20% off all right that's
it all right welcome back thank you
thank you thanks for having me back yeah
thanks for coming David MA
my brother it's cool I think I'm your
first interviewer that came back for a
second round right am i right I think
you are actually yeah interesting
because you were high in demand so I had
to bring it back cool
so just a little context in the the
previous video I made an interview with
you and it's mostly about how you were a
quant at 2 Sigma and then that video you
told me that you quit your job to do to
co-found a startup is that correct yeah
so a lot of people were wondering why
did you make the switch the switch
there's a lot of
small reasons I wanted to try something
new
wanting to see what was out there for
deep learning I wanted to also look at
cryptocurrencies I want to look at
biotech but in the end Elliott the
co-founder of dynasty reached out to me
like a week after I said I was gonna
quit and he was like hey have you ever
thought about quitting and I was like
did I quit like one week ago like how do
you how did you how did you do this hmm
and then didn't he said like yeah just
come out to LA and then see what we're
doing and then there's nothing no harm
done right yeah I got one thing led to
the next and you know Here I am now nice
nice so between back then when I
interviewed you to now any updates on
the startup is dynasty right yeah there
was a lot of a lot a lot happens since
since the last time we spoke I joined
dynasty at that time we had just pivoted
into the the AI for for real estate
business and during that time we built a
product found product market fit and
earlier this year we just sold to
appFolio and which is where I am
building out the product scaling it and
adapting the product to their client
base got it
- I asked how much did you guys sell it
for well it's public for people who want
to know mine if I do my research and put
on my video I guess I guess I can just
tell you because you're gonna put it out
anyways we sell for 60 million mm-hm
yeah nice
how many co-founders really yes so
dynasty was initially a different
business which did not succeed and
that's very that's very common for a lot
of startups so yeah at the end of the
last business everything was we were
like 10 people and I joined that as like
the sixth person and at that time things
we're not going well
there was no product market fit and we
started pivoting into the
real estate and about half the people
best oh so in terms of co-founder
originally there were two co-founders
and then this new will for the new pivot
five of us were left just a tldr what
was the previous product and what is the
product now just to make it more tear
back then we wanted to create I want to
securitize real estate assets basically
create a in exchange and then allowing
people with a smaller amount of capital
to take and take positions in real
estate assets if you think about it
right now you buy a house you have to
have you know especially in Silicon
Valley you have to have like 200k 300k
just to put it put down a deposit it's
not very democratic right and also your
all your money is into it just one
single assets that's very susceptible to
to local changes so we want to just
change that it didn't really work out we
at least we didn't find how to make it
work I'm not gonna say it's a bad idea
because we still think that you know
there are benefits to this world we're
dreaming of but in the process Eliot's
and other people who joined before me
found out that a lot of real estate
participants had a lot of trouble
managing their assets so it's unlike
stocks real estate as an asset that you
have to you know it's a real thing you
have to keep yeah there's up cave you
want to like get people into for rentals
and stuff like that I think half of the
the income comes from rectals right if
you take it the other half has
appreciation so one of the big
challenges was the operations of leasing
a building or leasing your assets so we
decided well everybody says it's a
problem so let's do something about it
yeah and that that's where Lisa
lisa is the second iteration of dynasty
so that's like the pivot that's your new
business that's right yeah
and of course Lisa is an AI for leasing
mmm-hmm I was wondering now that you've
you know dig your hands deep into ml are
there any misconceptions about ml
engineering that you want to debunk I
think the the general excitement about
ml is great it made a lot of people go
into ml a that and that's awesome but
like a lot of focus has been on how do I
build models and how do I fit a fitter
model to the data but like very little
focus has been on how do i generate data
how do I design a business process that
will create data for the algorithm that
I want to build how do I handle the
outputs how do I build all the process
around DML components yeah there's too
much focus on building the models not in
the focus on how to integrate ml into
existing products and to be fair it's
kind of a new field right
not many people how to know how to do
this because it's it's it's so new like
an analogy is when you know computers
were were first invented her like the
internet was first invented people were
finding out how to integrate that into
existing business processes and you know
it took a lot of trial and error but
that's the same thing like not
everything is just building models right
yeah not everything becomes more useful
if there's machine learning in it yeah
right maybe not everything should use
blockchain technology exactly right
that's what that's the example I want to
use like I always wondered a lot of
people want to do machine learning now
my viewers especially because I think
it's because I'm in the intersection of
data science and software engineering
but I don't I don't really understand
the appeal of machine learning at the
job because in my mind what you do is
like you said you make sure you have
good data make sure you solve a problem
with your ml so most of the time in my
head
build data pipelines to funnel it into
your model you pick a model you play
with the you tune the parameters and
then try to optimize for that AUC and
then that's it like is or is there more
to it I don't know that is fun I I think
like you're you're kind of right I mean
especially if you're building products
you know you don't have the time to do
the fun stuff in ml research the way I
see it software engineering is the the
core skill and then there's like ml
engineering that that gives you a bit
more domain knowledge into how to build
an old products or ml models but in the
end once you once you've done that like
a v1 of it that's it you have to you
have to build all of the systems around
it and that's not what the school is on
what you really learn at school mm-hm
so imagine the fun stuff that machine
learning researchers do what is that
what is the fun stuff what would be fun
for me I think in terms of research
would be you know investigating the
latest algorithms and like understanding
why they work why they don't trying
different data sets on these new
algorithms a lot of the things that
you've seen out there like Gans like
generative adversarial networks you make
like funky images style transfers like
these are all investigations and why do
convolutional networks work as they do
and that's research right and that's not
it's not primarily those things were not
built primarily for business good
and of course lisa is an AI for leasing
the pun one of the problems that people
had was like when you put your your your
apartment for on Zillow or something
like that you get a ton of inbound you
have a you have emails you have text
messages you have phone calls like it's
the it's very fragmented the things that
you get and you have to take all of that
in Bound coordinate showings take care
of applications and I do all that
move-in process so Lisa what we decided
to do was to automate the the responses
to text messages emails phone calls and
on the other side we just produced
showing so people just had to show up
and obvious the leasing agents just had
to help to show up and sell sell the
property they didn't have to like
coordinate and do all that stuff and
that was the main the main focus of it I
think a lot of people liked how you know
their phone stopped ringing after they
used they started using anybody said you
know okay cool awesome so what about you
what did you do in dynasty yeah you
worked on Visa I guess yeah of course so
originally I was hired for to do some
research because you know I was a
researcher blah blah blah but you know
nothing turns out as we plan it and I
decided to take that opportunity to dive
into ml I mean I had some ml experiences
back in college and a little bit back at
my previous job but never deeply so I
decided to build out the the ml
components got into deep learning learn
about NLP which is natural language
processing and once that core thing was
built you know we were still startup we
just had to do other things so I got
myself into a software engineering you
know before that had never done like
real software engineering
but under our CTO I was able to learn a
lot about you know how to build how to
build products and like yes I did
software engineering and product design
yes basically you have to do everything
at a startup mmm-hmm so why why couldn't
other people just do the same thing just
apply AI to real estate stuff and then
would they be a competitor like how why
what made dynasty successful mm-hmm
we also thought that there was going to
be competitors and I think there there
are but nobody took the symbol of the
exact approach that we did which was
Lisa would talk to two prospects
prospects being the people who would
rent they were protecting them without
telling them that they it's a bot or
anything because in reality were not
fully about either about 40% of our
messages are handled by humans who we
call operators the fact that we try to
give such a natural experience to
prospect is something that the clients
really liked because in general people
don't like to interact with the bottom
so our conversations look very natural
because there's a lot of humans that
kind of that we fall back to when things
go wrong actually I have a funny story
about people not liking to interact with
buzz
so one of the one thing that we measured
was how often would people reply when we
send messages back to them right it's
like reply ratio whatever initially we
would reply instantaneously because
people would message in and were like
hey we have a showing at 2:30 you want
to come like within seconds and then the
I mean people were probably freaked out
and replied less than if we were to wait
two minutes
before replying so although we can reply
very quickly sometimes we wait a minute
or two before doing so that's
interesting so another part that made us
successful I think was the fact well I
think the biggest the biggest success
was the the market validation that was
done prior to the pivot but that aside
another thing was our willingness to
just build what was was needed and like
not focus on technology too much and
just get something out out there we get
it in front of people iterate and build
it as simply as possible so that we
don't waste too much energy trying to
optimize a system that was not going to
exist like a week later yeah and also
these days AI products are like very I
really hot a lot of people spend a lot
of time optimizing that small small
component which it in retrospect like I
could have spent more time on that but
if I did that I wouldn't have liked use
my time to build out the product in
terms of the software engineering part
right
deciding to say okay that's good enough
and work on like the most important part
for the business was at where something
was I was spirit that like everybody had
at Dynasty and I think that really
mmm-hmm
you know pushed us beyond the edge okay
give me a concrete example of that thing
you just described like what could have
you optimized on like how did your ml
system work as a whole what was that
part of that ml system that you could
have optimized on but what did you work
on instead to make your product better
in the backend the the first ml
component that we we created was an
intent classifier so we would take in
messages and understand was the intent
classify them
one of a few intents like do they want
showing did they accept something like
whatever Oh actually before we continue
can I just kind of have a high-level
overview of what Lisa does because right
now I think it's kind of just like a
chatbot for leasing yeah and then is
there anything that does like how does
it interact with the operators and also
the clients right so Lisa is a pretty
complicated product in terms of how you
would explain it like with components
that you understand because there's a
lot of interactions one interaction is
with the prospect so with through there
we it's just a bunch of text or emails
the first text comes in we ask them do
they want a showing then the
conversation can go anywhere they can
ask questions about the property they
can't like you know decide not to do
anything we have to confirm them for the
showing like we asked them how how it's
going that's one interaction with the
agents the leasing agents we schedule
things on their calendar we ask them
questions that that we don't know the
answer of we answer questions that they
they have for us and there's like an
interaction with bosses well which
bosses the bosses a real estate agent
boss correct okay sometimes the same
person but like often it's not they want
reporting so that's a that's the main
interaction and then there's our human
operators which uses Lisa as like an
interface to the outside world they have
what we call the command center and it's
mostly like a messenger interface but
like augmented with a lot of information
and also they have a concept called the
quick action which they can quickly find
a a commonly used action to reply to
prospects
awesome okay so that means back then
real estate agent will have to
communicate with the prospects do the
showing scheduled your own showing
manage your own calendar but now they
actually don't even need to talk to the
prospects and you just have Lisa that is
kind of like a layer in between that's
right down oh that's really cool until
they get to the showing which I don't
you know they want to use their human
specialty to do the cell you know well I
mean one day you could build robots and
just replace that - okay one day way
cool okay so now that we have a good
overview let's go back to what are the
ml parts that are very specific I'm
pretty sure there's ml in the quick
reply
there's probably ml in trying to
classify what messages are so what
weren't the other stuff that you could
that you worked on that was better for
the business and then just optimizing
that okay once we got the the intent
classifiers we could have you know tried
better models like bird or Elmo like the
stuff that came out in 2008 it was
really hot we could have tried using
that to you know gain a few percentage
points of accuracy or those models like
NLP Manos that's right okay yeah we used
something like pretty simple like a Tec
CNN for our core models and it worked it
worked fine
but like you know sure could we have
done better
we're still trying someone we have time
but like there are more important parts
to work on in Canada mm-hmm like the
what like the question Tiger was born
out of necessity and like they were they
were answering the questions over and
over again so like finding other places
to to the package by the ML solution is
more impactful than trying to optimize
the existing components got it yeah
mm-hmm so what do you think most
startups hmm make as mistakes using ml
like what are the common mistakes
startups make using ml because I'm
guessing you're comparing your dynasty
to other startups
how'd they do what would they do wrong
my guess would be focusing too much on
the latest technology that's out there
especially the academic literature and
trying to apply that to their business
it takes time to pour academic
literature to mature for business and a
lot of a lot of literature is sometimes
not reproducible mmm and it's a common
problem so like investing too much there
will waste a lot of time and as a
start-up you don't have a lot of time
got it yeah I heard a lot of people
saying that in theory the paper sounds
great and it works with their data set
but applying it is a whole different
story
yeah applying you have to so finding a
way to apply ml to a business
environment is difficult because you
have to specifically know which problem
like this isn't in itself is like many
many problems and you have to carve out
one specific problem for ML it has to be
worth it or at the time of research you
have to be able to find a process that
will generate data for that problem and
once your algorithm is working you have
false positives you have false negatives
you have to have a process to handle
that and then not even including
monitoring like making sure that your
models are are always performing as well
as you think they are in our business
with Lisa it's generally pretty it's not
too bad because like English generally
doesn't change but you know maybe if
you're working on ads or like trading
your environment will change and your
algorithm performance might decay and
you have you have to like know about
that know so there's a lot of stuff that
happens around that there's no small ml
component so from what I understand it
seems like it's better to build out your
system understanding what you have to do
how to do everything and then identify
what are your spots that need ml and
then solve for that rather than some
other companies with
identify maybe even an mo problem and
then build out a solution like
everything else which ultimately may be
that solution wasn't even that useful
for the market anyways right okay
awesome
so oh yeah I think I think another
pitfall would be trying to solve too
much with ml all right like there was a
you know there's a few companies out
there that wanted to build personal
assistants and it turns out the job of
personal assistant is like extremely
difficult and there's like infinite
variations right even in our business of
leasing we found that it's a very subtle
hmm taking the the very simple example
of what's the rent you know you think
that's a simple answer it's a simple
question at first but then you have to
say you think okay well actually what
are they talking about the one-bedroom a
two-bedroom are they talking about
moving now are moving later are they
talking about one one one-year lease or
two-year lease oh wait are you talking
about the like about all our properties
or like only the ones that are available
yeah there's a lot of tricky C's
intricacies in in a simple question just
as like what is the rent yeah and I also
know it's quite difficult because I'm
trying to hire a real personal assistant
and that is still very hard so I'm
guessing you know because if you can't
even solve my problems with a real human
I don't even know how to start solving
with them like machine learning model
because usually I think if something is
easy to solve manually like a replica
lots of repetition then you can kind of
replace it with AI but yeah yes that's
actually one of the guidelines that we
have if we want to carve out something
for the 4ml first solve it with humans
see how I could work see how it works if
it's really repetitive and like people
make don't make a lot of mistakes right
some heuristics
not even ml and run run with it for a
while
handle your handle your false-positives
handle your false negatives and if the
system is humming then you know try to
increase the accuracy with with ml mm
but without these intermediate steps
like don't even think about it
mm-hmm all right so Dynasty are you guys
are you guys hiring
you know yes yeah we're definitely
hiring right now you know we need a lot
of good engineers the the way we we want
to hire is hiring people who have a
decent software engineering experience
because we don't currently have a lot of
time to to bring people up to speed
because we're still a start-up even
though we required and we want general
software engineering skills we think
that that will translate well into the
ml parts or if you focus on you know
more systems reliability or like more
product but like the core software
engineering skill is what we're looking
for okay what kind of technologies would
they be working with if they want to be
an applied machine learning engineer we
we use like typical stuff like tensor
flow you know the Python packages and
stuff like that our stack on the backend
is Java again our pragmatism we don't we
don't try to use too many fancy latest
technologies we just use what is tried
and proven so really that's kind of our
core philosophies mm-hmm right so what
would make a good machine learning
engineer a good hire for you what kind
of skills are not just skills but
attributes personal attributes yeah
willing to dig into the details
understanding the business not like
focusing too much on on the ml part
being good at software engineering in
general I dynasty we're not like ml
engineers are not are not like oh I'm
the ml guy and
you can you guys can do like the back
end like you have to do you have to do
this on for engineering you don't get
like an assistant for that mmm yeah so
what's next for you and dynasty ended
next five years
mm-hmm yeah five years is a long time I
mean just a year and a half ago it was a
different business yeah
now - yeah two years ago thanks it was a
different thing definitely for me I want
to see Lisa built out to its full
potential
hopefully you know the viewers will well
someday rent an apartment I'd be talking
to Lisa and after that who knows I think
I'll be at appFolio for the foreseeable
future
yeah well maybe I'll be building other
ml products hopefully finding other ways
to apply ml into the real world
mm-hmm awesome cool yeah thank you so
much and I just want to say best of luck
to Lisa
dynasty and appFolio if they do want to
apply to dynasty do they have to do it
through appFolio website or is there a
separate dynasty website we are fully
under at full wear now okay so you
should apply to a folio exactly so and
then if you want to prepare for appFolio
don't forget to check out Tech and be
pearls all right I got taking intro if
you're interested in getting ready for
interviews oh yeah I also want to plug
my Twitter em a David J M a David J [ __ ]
a ghost's cool all right thank you so
much for being here really appreciate it
Thank You private
all right